overd
Drive let's
[Music]
go hey y this is SK and these are
Essentials okay let's cover the Brand
This is a box of Y and this is a bom and
this is two of the three things that you
need to make mate we're missing hot
water but whatever basically I watch a
lot of sport mainly football the real
one and uh a lot of South American
players they're always drinking it so I
got curious and uh I found out that
gives you a lot of energy so for me it's
very good and before the stage I don't
drink coffee I only drink this the
grandpa my second essional is my
notebook this is where I write basically
whatever comes to my mind uh songs
tattoos ideas I don't write anything
with my phone I only write down with my
handwriting because otherwise my mind
tends to erase things so if I lose this
I lose my career not a song that is not
released
uh
oh this is trust no way this is the
first uh
we're going to be very
quick
H people are going to
scen my third essential is my grinder
and my Kings siiz paper you know for
what it is I think I love this grinder
because it's called cheap as
I love that I love that because
when when I got into the shop I said ah
do you have a grinder and the guy was
yeah whatever what what type do you want
and I'm not like very fancy on these
things so I was like just the cheapest
one I don't give a and cheapest
[Music]
so my first essential are my giant
sunglasses so I can hide myself when I'm
too hungover or I don't want to do
makeup before very good to hide yourself
you are recognizable like oh it's
perfect no it's like my hand of antenna
wig like actually the pair I use the
most theano broke at a g two weeks ago
so I couldn't bring my real first use I
don't know like uh I I took them off on
stage and then somebody put it back in
the car maybe with not uh enough care so
I have I don't believe this it's just an
excuse yeah
sure my second essential but in reality
my first and most important essential
are these gums every time I eat
something as soon as I'm finished I need
a gum cuz otherwise I don't I feel bad
so I always need gums this Italian gums
and it's the best so super strong but
it's really ugly if you fall asleep with
them in your mouth cuz if you should
never fall asleep with a gum in your
mouth it's but you never did no
I never really what it's dangerous I
fall asleep so many times it's not nice
but it happens a couple
times so my third essential is my $2
bill and we got these in a from the $2
bill man which we didn't knew existed
but apparently there is a man in La that
goes around with a bunch of $2 and give
them to people he says they bring good
luck so I've keeping them with me since
two years and I have a big bunch at home
that I give out to the ones who deserve
I must admit that dollars are more swag
than Euros it's probably because we're
we're grown up with American movies and
like dollars are pretty fascinating for
us no and also I always have them in my
cover of my phone which is transparent
always show your money before your
persona your persona my $2 Rich
[Music]
bit this camera my city digital camera
in which I have all the nudes of
everyone in this band so it's very
precious and I could one day sell them
on only fence it's a money machine I
bought it like in a vintage market so it
came with this actually it's so scammed
because in Rome in ital these cameras
they're like 5€ 10 and the other day I
was at the Market flea market here in LA
and I go and it was like exactly the
same camera I'm like wow nice how much
is it
$140 you against scam Italians I'm sorry
exactly so I've got this from my Italian
flea market and I'll keep it we invented
that practice
yeah don't play with us so Ethan it's
your turn oh
my first essential this is a little
Zippo and it's just lighter basically
why the lighter though because you never
know when you need fire sometimes so you
never know you you can't create Fire by
yourself right so you need a lighter or
you need like stones but it's pretty
hard to find around so this is a perfect
thing to have if you need fire it's like
now now it's not
working my second essential item just
give me 30
seconds oh my
God about dirtiest glasses i' ever seen
glasses when we play like on stage and
like in the first line of the crowd
everybody is like you know please can
you you know like can you say hi to me
and every time I'm like this because I
can't really see anything but I actually
like use them when I had to watch TV or
if I had to drive you know so it's hard
for oh God it is yeah if you have to
look smart right we don't care about
being smart we just want to be
hot my third essential item my little
and cute scrunch I usually use it for
this which will be very strange to see
like for the first time is very weird
but it's actually very useful because
while we're playing I have the pedal
that like the drum pedal that goes back
and forth and sometimes it goes inside
this and so when I kick it it doesn't
sound because it doesn't kick the the
drum hat this is why this so important
not only for me but for everybody so no
Kick Drum no gig no Kick Drum no party
so no scrunchy no no
[Applause]
[Music]
party My First Essential thank you
guys this is just for the swag I would
say you always wear this
yeah and me and Thomas we always have a
battle on who is more stylish and every
time we have to go to parties and stuff
he always wears this and he's like haha
look my suit is going so I'm like okay
but you're cheating cuz it's the same
every time no there's not you always
buys a new one no yeah the same but no
no that's not true that's not true I
love of course like uh dress well and
stuff like that I think that the suits
it's really cool and the boots of course
like the star with the star actually
like I think that the star the element
of Victoria probably cuz uh she has lots
of stars like in the base right yeah but
you are the star you know it's
[Music]
baby next essential is of course at the
guitar and in case you didn't know
exactly who are your like Guitar Gods
probably Jimmy Paige also love Jimmy
andrick Richie
Blackmore I love to write new songs cool
Reef in my old room and a lot of times
we wrote some songs like during the tour
so this really nice and good I think
useful my Essential is this tiny
amplifier it's really cool cuz like the
problem of course if I can have like a
huge amplifier when we are around so
this is very nice 1 five Vols three
black liners thank you guys overdrive
exactly everything get done everything
gets
done let's
[Applause]
[Music]
go